hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide today we're going to
be going over something that is pretty
well known and that is tanning Dragon
hides uh yet it is surprisingly
profitable I was making up to 1 mil an
hour by tanning the red dragon hide uh
but there are benefits and drawbacks to
all of them and we are going to go over
them quickly on top of that we are going
to be giving away another GE tracker
membership so it's going to be the same
as the first time leave a comment with
your G tracker username as well as uh
like the video and subscribe to my
channel do those three things and uh
we're going to pick another random uh
winner for a one month uh free premium
membership so hope you guys enjoy and
let's jump into it okay guys so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start with 10 mil that is going to be
enough to buy uh enough leather to tan
for exactly 1 hour
approximately and what we're going to do
is we're going to try a quarter of each
type of dragon hi High to see uh which
is the most effective now some I know
are going to be more profitable uh but
they also will sell slower we're going
to do a bit of each just to test them
all out and uh we're going to use G
tracker a link will be in the
description for that uh it's going to
give you just a quick overview of what
the profits looking like has a tan
leather option too if you're actually
using the lunar spell book which I don't
have now but maybe we'll save that for
another video uh now we're just going to
be tanning Dragon hides and alar rid
looks like red dragon hiide is the most
uh profitable uh that being said it
probably does trade the least and uh we
can have a look here yeah it's only 50
to 70,000 a day where say like black
dragon hi I think might be
200,000 and uh yeah closer 200,000 and
green dragon hide will be the most
popular definitely by far I think it's
up to like a million of these or
something maybe not quite but still
quite a lot anyway let's get started
we'll start with the red dragon hi highs
it will be the slowest to buy and sell
so to check the margin it's really easy
all we're going to do is uh buy one of
the finished product which is going to
be the red dragon leather and then we
also have to test what we're going to
buy the actual uh material goods for and
we'll buy and sell the dragon
hide okay so we're going to collect
everything okay so we're going to sell
our product for 3189 and we're going to
buy it for
2805 keep in mind that we're going to
take off 20 GP cuz that's how much it
cost to tan it and not how much our
margin is going to be um theoretically
we should be able to do 2,800 in an hour
and uh well just we do 2800 that looks
like we're going to make a mill an hour
doing this uh but again it does have a
drawback of being the slowest item but
that being said we'll definitely go buy
some uh do
28066 and we're going to do 700 of
these perfect and and uh now we'll just
move on to the green dragon hide do this
a little quicker now again we're just
going to buy the dragon
leather and then we're going to buy the
green dragon
hide and then sell it
again uh now the green dragon hide I
believe has the opposite it is the
lowest margin by far um if you're not
counting cow leather which we're not U
but it will buy and sell the quickest so
we're going to take off uh the Buy price
from this so it's
1685 looking to make about
168 U minus the 20 of course so we'll
put it in 4
1686 and do 700 of
these so now know that's what I know the
I knew this would be the most uh
expensive and this would be the least or
most profitable sorry and this would be
the least profitable now for the blue
and black dragon hiide I'm not actually
sure they generally fluctuate to be
close or not not um wow we're buying
these very quickly so we'll take uh the
blue dragon hide and then we will my god
look how quickly that is buying uh yeah
well it is a heavily botted item so I'm
not really surprised at all we'll be
probably done buying it by the time we
even finish this clip uh so we'll try to
hurry
up all right so for blue dragon hide
we're looking at 2329 minus
2101 uh so we're going to get about 200
GP margin on this so not too
bad
2102 and do 700 of
these and uh last up is the black dragon
hide now black dehy I think is the most
consistently profitable and by that I
mean it uh has the highest
margin uh but it does still trade a lot
so you won't be waiting on it where the
red de High definitely has the largest
margin pretty much all the time but uh
it does trade very
slowly and look at that we're already
done buying the green dragon hiide so
we'll just finish up this black dragon
hiide here and then we'll wait for the
rest of the offers to
complete looks like on the black dragon
hide we are going to be
getting 214 so it's actually a little
bit less than the blue dragon hide which
is a little surprising uh but we'll
definitely still do it as well so 3366
and uh
700 and there we go guys so we have
successfully spent about 7 mil uh we
totally bought two of the items already
so hopefully the rest will buy soon and
uh then we'll go tan
them okay guys so we're back and uh we
did buy everything so I'm going to give
you a time frame on how long it actually
took to buy uh as you saw the green
Dragonite and blue dragon hiide took
under 5 minutes so very quick for those
ones black dragon hiide probably took 20
minutes and the red dragony probably
took an hour and a half to buy uh so you
can see obviously red Dragonite takes
the longest black Dragonite takes to
next longest probably blue is a little
bit slower than green but it's all
pretty relative you'd probably buy them
quicker than you would actually tan them
anyway so go ahead and collect
everything boom and uh we have just our
test buies here our cash in the
inventory and dueling ring to get to ald
cuz that is where we're going to be
tanning now now I think this is the
closest one and definitely the most
easiest to get to um and the only other
thing that might be useful here is
having uh the grace ball set or other
weight reducing equipment not necessary
by any means but it will speed up your
uh leather Tans per hour and yeah we're
going to start by tanning the red dragon
hide uh cuz then we're going to probably
pop it into cell cuz it does probably
take a lot longer and uh yeah we'll come
back when we've made some progress so I
know this is 2017 and most people know
how to do this uh but it's worth noting
that um I'm going to be using stamina
potions uh so some people may not
realize that this is definitely going to
be worth it uh because okay you're going
to drink a dose of stamina potion being
able to run the whole time increases the
amount of hides you can tan per hour
from 2,000 roughly to 2,800 and to do I
use stamina potions for an hour uh it's
only going to cost about 50k so it's
definitely worth uh investing in the
stamina potions because you'll get way
more runs per hour and easily make back
the cost of the potions as well as I
possibly understated the usefulness of
the graceful set while not required
definitely will help uh save on stamina
potions as well as increase your GP per
hour all right like I said we're
starting with the red dragon hides and I
think this should be our last inventory
it took actually a little bit under 15
minutes so I think I could probably get
a little bit more than 2800 done uh but
2800 is a nice Baseline kind of had a
nice even amount but there we go we're
done the red dragon hide we're going to
move on to the green dragon hide I think
and there we are guys that is the last
inventory of the green dragon hide uh
definitely the least profitable but I'm
sure this will sell in under 5 minutes
so I'm not worried about it and yeah I
think next up we're going to do the uh
blue dragon hiide all right there we go
Blue Dragon hide has been completed uh
worth noting is H you're not getting any
experience from this method so it kind
of comes at a cost but it can be done at
level three so it definitely has its
benefits uh Last Dragon hi High we're
going to T is the black dragon hide then
we will be done that's it guys so we're
going to sell the black dragon hide and
then we will go ahead and price check it
on the grand exchange and see how much
money we actually made in 1 hour um kind
of predicting about 700 or 800k because
we did uh do a combination of the four
uh but we'll see all right guys so
everything has sold uh again the green
and blue dragon had sold within minutes
black dragon ey probably took maybe like
closer to half an hour and the red
dragon ey took about an hour to sell I
sold all one chunk mind you and it did
so how much per hour would we have
gotten uh from each of these Dragon
Leathers so the most profitable by far
was the drag red dragon hide uh had we
done an hour's worth of this we would
have gotten 1 mil and 26k in the hour
after that the next most profitable item
was the blue dragon hide uh which would
have given us 62k per hour after that
surprisingly the green dragon hide ended
up being more profitable at 4 88k per
hour and the black Dron hide
unfortunately must have tanked a little
bit cuz we would only have gotten 384k
per hour but these prices do fluctuate a
lot I have gotten almost a m per hour
taning black dragon hides before as well
as blue dragon hides but it doesn't
happen all the time so I hope you guys
enjoyed let's see how much we actually
got in the uh hour of doing this we got
about 663k so that's kind of a average
of all of these
hourly rates combined so you can get
upwards of 1 mil per hour and really as
low as about
400k and uh that's it guys pretty easy I
know a lot of you probably already know
how to do this but you never know so
hope you guys enjoyed the video and I'll
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
pap